. OK, let's go to the phone lines at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty and
see what is on people's minds, starting with
our caller from the six, seven, eight.
Caller from the six, seven, eight area code.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Inhaling Yes, I can.
OK.
Yeah, I called you want support?
So.
And given my profession is very important
for you, you've been living.
Sorry, I'm having a hard time hearing you
said.
Are there protests where I'm living?
Yes.
Yeah, there's there's been prostatic protests
in Boston, both in the downtown areas, in
the Forest Hills area, which is a little bit
outside of the city in Brockton, which is
really not Boston.
It's the Boston area.
There's been a bunch of protests.
Yeah.
My main question is I see mostly the young
people standing up for, you know, people like
George Boyd.
And yet the boomers tend to look they always
in the side to police no matter what they
do.
Why is it the boomers?
They always look down upon us forever questioning
this dashboard when they were the ones during
Vietnam protesting this dad?
Well, what changed with them that made them
so status quo ish?
That's interesting.
Well, so there's two parts.
I mean, part one is once you live with a system
for a while and you feel that the system sort
of works for you, you're less likely to demand
that the system be radically changed.
You with me sort of on that part, at least
to start with.
Yeah, now, I guess the other thing.
So in terms of the protests, there is no doubt
that the people protesting are disproportionately
younger folks.
I don't know that that's hugely surprising.
It seems to me that at every era it is overwhelmingly
people between 20 and 40, 20 and 45 that are
doing the protesting.
And I think it's just by by that I don't know
that that's unique to this situation.
When you look at the ages of arrest.
It's been mostly like 18 to 35 year olds.
I don't know that that means older folks aren't.
If you look at the polling, it seems the country
is pretty united on on the Floyd fiasco.
All right.
I just had, like I car what my mother, who
is saying if it doesn't involve them, my mother
only my mother, my own mother, things that
it doesn't involve her and her her kids and
grandkids.
She shouldn't get involved.
I just don't understand how people can just
be so blind.
Well, unfortunately, it is not uncommon that
a lot of folks don't really care much about
an issue or consider it seriously until it
affects them.
Look at all these Republican congressmen who
are anti-gay their whole lives.
Then their kid, like their nephew, is gay.
And they're like, you know what?
I've seen the light.
Now we need to do this.
We need to do that.
That's a sad reality about humanity that you've
stumbled across.
I don't think it's unique to your mom.
Yeah, yeah.
That's just like Bill Marcal.
That the empathy gap.
Yeah.
Hey, Mom, I'm going to let you go.
Thank you for answering my question.
That actually makes a lot of sense.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you, my friend.
Great to hear from you.
Thank you so much.